okay so the topic of this video today is
nucleic acids nucleic acids are one of
the four categories of organic molecules
so let's get started so here's a picture
of a blueprint to build a boat you might
know that a blueprint is really just a
set of building instructions and you're
often gonna hear nucleic acids
specifically DNA compared to a blueprint
well what does that mean about DNA then
what it means is nucleic acids and DNA
we'll get to DNA in a little more
specifics later but nucleic acids are
blueprints they're instructions they
contain information and in this case
they contain informations on how to link
together a bunch of amino acids into
what's called a protein without the
instructions found within the nucleic
acids our cells would not be able to
build proteins and so because of this we
often call nucleic acids as an analogy
of a blueprint well there's two types of
nucleic acids Mallett molecules called
DNA on the left and RNA on the right and
we'll talk some specifics about each in
just a moment but the N in the a in
their abbreviations stand for nucleic
acids now any nucleic acid is composed
of building blocks called monomers and
in this case the monomer of a nucleic
acid is called a nucleotide
so one nucleotide would be a monomer but
when a bunch of nucleotides are bonded
together this makes a polymer again the
word polymer is kind of a generic
description in this case the power mer
is called a nucleic acid now when we
look at the structure and more close
detail of a nucleotide a nucleotide we
just said a moment ago what's a
nucleotide
it's the monomer it's the building block
of a nucleic acid and so if we take one
single nucleotide here now in reality
nucleotides are not just an orange
circle that's incredibly generic and
symbolic if we zoom out in what we see
are three different shapes and
and these shapes are we even pretty
generic and symbolic as well but these
three shapes represent the three sub
parts of a nucleotide there is the first
part the the blue Pentagon with the s in
the middle well this is the sugar
molecule here's an actual diagram here
of what the sugar molecule looks like
notice you can see why we tend to use
Pentagon's to symbolically show the
sugar molecule because the carbons in
the middle are kind of arranged in a
pentagon configuration and then there is
the black circle with the letter P that
stands for the phosphate group and this
is a diagram of the actual phosphate
group right here and you have to use
your imagination a little bit but you're
often gonna see just phosphate groups
kind of drawn as a circle just uh just
know that the circle part that that's
our phosphate group and then there's the
really interesting part of a nucleotide
the nitrogen base there's four nitrogen
bases and we symbolically identify them
by letters of the alphabet and a stands
for a nitrogen base called adenine you
might know from middle school that
there's a nitrogen base T for thymine
nitrogen base C for cytosine and a
nitrogen base G for guanine now these
are the parts in the nucleotide that are
really special because it's the order of
these a's and t's and c's and g's that
we have inherited from our parents the
order of these a's and t's and c's and
g's is the instructions that we
referenced earlier how nucleic acids are
our instructions they're like a
blueprint and so the sequence of these
a's and t's and c's and g's these are
the instructions and so one thing to
mention we said a moment ago nucleotides
here's a single nucleotide let me add a
few more nucleotides will combine with
one another in order to to form a larger
polymer that we call a nucleic acid and
so here we have a nucleic acid made from
up a made from about a dozen or so
nucleotides
well let's go ahead and stop the notes
for a moment and let's kind of see what
we can answer so you know pause the
video try to answer these six questions
I'm going to go over the answers in
three two one so even though this video
is about one of the four categories of
organic molecule there are four and
those would be the nucleic acids
proteins lipids and carbohydrates today
we're talking about nucleic acids in
that picture right there what would you
call that long chain of nucleotides well
those aren't that would be a nucleic
acid and how many nucleotides do you see
pictured count the individual building
blocks and you'll see six of them number
four name the blue Pentagon shaped
molecules well that's the sugar the
sugar of the nucleotides and number five
what are the individual monomers called
well we know there's six of them and
those individual monomers building
blocks are called nucleotides and number
six what will these instructions be used
to create the instructions of nucleic
acids are used to build proteins so
let's continue and see let's continue on
so let's talk about DNA a little more
closely deoxyribonucleic acid you're
often hear its structure its shape
called a double helix what this means is
there are two chains of nucleotides that
twist and wrap around themselves kind of
like a spiral staircase will twist and
wrap around itself and we can thank this
discovery to an American by the name of
James Watson and an Englishman by the
name of Francis Crick in the early 1950s
they built a model they built a model of
of a DNA molecule and the model kind of
looked like this diagram right here you
can see it twists around itself and
notice how there are inside of the model
are these what appear to be steps that
go up up the inside of the model we're
gonna be talking about these in a lot
more detail so what they uncovered was
that again because the name double helix
that implies two so here's one chain of
nucleotides on the left and then a
second chain of nucleotides on the right
so they uncovered the structure of DNA
how its built how its assembled and
notice in between the a and the T on the
left and right in between the season the
G's on the left and right there are
these flashing lines here these were
symbolic of what are called hydrogen
bonds these are the bonds that hold the
left chain of nucleotides to the right
chain of nucleotides but let's look at
those A's and T's in more detail let's
look at those season G's in more detail
now when the two sides do link together
there's a pairing rule there's a
scientist named Hermann chargaff who
discovered that when he was examining
DNA DNA always had the same amount of
adenine as it did thymine he didn't
understand why this was it wasn't
discovered until years later but the
reason molecules have the same amount of
a for adenine in the same amount of tea
for thymine is because they're bonded
together and we now call this chargaff's
rule here's the first of chartres gas
rule and here's the second the second of
chartres gas rules a pairs to t is rule
1 C pairs to G or cytosine pairs to
guanine is rule number 2 so again what
he discovered what Aaron chargaff
discovered was that A's and T's were
always found in equal amounts c's and
g's were always found in equal amounts
and even though he didn't know that they
paired together at the time it was
eventually discovered a few years later
and so when we look at this picture we
can see char gas rules everywhere
there's an A on one side of the DNA
molecule there's a T on the other
everywhere there's a C on one side
there's a G on the other and so a pairs
to T and C pairs to G and now here's a
big piece of DNA I wanted to talk about
what a gene is a gene is just a small
piece a small segment of DNA that holds
instructions to make a protein for
instance let's call that sequence right
there gene a pretend those instructions
will tell your cells how to make a
protein called hemoglobin hemoglobin is
the protein on red blood cells that
carries oxygen well here's another gene
here's another highlighted area of
DNA pretend this is gene B these
instructions will eventually tell your
cells maybe how to make a protein called
keratin keratin is a protein that's
found in your hair makes her hair all
shiny and healthy and then again a gene
is a small segment of DNA here's another
gene you can see some genes are bigger
than others some genes are smaller than
others genes see let's pretend these
instructions will eventually tell your
cells how to make a protein called
collagen collagen is the protein in your
skin that gives it its stretching this
and eventually as you get older your
collagen breaks down and your skin gets
wrinkly and a little saggy but what I
want to mention is that what our genes
genes are small pieces of DNA they're
instructions they tell your cells how to
make various proteins in your body so
here's a picture right here how many
nucleotides do you see in this picture
pause I'm gonna go over the answer in
three two one
well you can see in the bottom left
we've highlighted one nucleotide so
that's what a nucleotide looks like
here's notice how there are six on the
left and because DNA is a double helix
there must be six on the right for a
total of twelve well so now that we know
a little bit about what DNA is and its
structure I want to present you with
this idea here well here's a cell and
inside of the box the box is the cell
and inside of the cell is a piece of DNA
now cells will as they go through their
life begin to grow and then they divide
through a process called mitosis where
they split themselves in half but look
we have a problem right now the cell on
the right has no DNA inside of it the
one cells split into two cells but the
cell on the right has no DNA in it well
good news there's a solution and before
cells divide they tend to make copies of
their DNA so let's reset this
okay so when we reset this what tends to
happen is the cell will make a copy of
its DNA so for a short period of time
cells will have double the DNA two
copies of DNA and then the cell will go
through its its cycle where it does
mitosis and it grows and it splits
itself into two and notice how the
solution of making more DNA before the
cell divides has ensured that each cell
has a copy of DNA to use throughout its
life and so that's what we're gonna look
at next how two cells do this how do
they make copies of their DNA well so
let's look at that process the process
of copying DNA this is called DNA
replication so here's a piece of DNA a
spiritu T's and C's pair to G's here's a
piece of DNA now as I said a moment ago
when cells go through their life they
eventually grow and they divide themself
in half interphase is the name of the
step before cells do this so before
cells divide by mitosis they are in a
step of their cycle called interphase
and that's when DNA replication occurs
and so let's break it down this into
some steps there's an enzyme by the name
of DNA helicase and I like to use
animated scissors to represent the
actions of an enzyme
so here's DNA helicase and what it does
is it unzips or breaks apart the bonds
between the C and the G breaks apart the
bonds the hydrogen bonds between the a
and the T breaks apart the bonds between
this am T breaks apart the bonds between
the G and C between the a and T between
the C and the G so you might often hear
that DNA helicase unzips the double
helix separates the left strip of
nucleotides from the right strip of
nucleotides that's gonna set us up for
step number two this is all taking place
in the nucleus there are free-floating
nucleotides a's t's c's and g's that
will match up to the ones that are now
exposed look on the left side there's a
C on top what's going to float in and
match to the
on the top left that would be a G the
next one down that would be an A the
next one down that would be a T you can
see all we're doing is applying in
shower gaffes rules here the next one
down there is a see the next one down T
next one down G and as that's happening
on the left piece of DNA the same thing
is happening on the right side only in
this case this time from the bottom up
so look at the bottom right there's a G
on the bottom right a C will match the
next one up in a the next one up a G the
next one up a the next one up T the next
one up C you can see all we did was
apply shower gaffes rules here
matching A's with T's and C's with G's
okay so that's gonna take us now to step
number three there's a different enzyme
this enzyme I'm not going to use a pair
of animated scissors because this enzyme
doesn't break apart this enzyme called
DNA polymerase is more like a bottle of
glue DNA polymerase helps to reestablish
the bonds between the C and the G
nitrogen bases and so one by one the
bonds between the A's and the T's the
bonds between the Seas and the G's are
being re-established almost like they're
being glued back together now on the
right hand side the same thing happens
same thing happens only in the opposite
direction the C and the G the a and the
T the G and the C and so on as we move
up and one by one the the two pieces of
DNA are now reglued together and when we
stop and examine we can see that both
pieces of DNA are identical to one
another look at the sequence the top
nucleotides are both cng the next one
downs our DNA the third one down our am
T and so on all the way down they are
exactly identical to one another this is
how your cells make a copy of their DNA
right before they divide in half
well know what if something goes wrong
in this copying process in the act of
making more pieces of DNA what if
there's a mistake
what if there's what we call a mutation
a change or an error in the DNA sequence
if you look at the picture there's a
mutation can you find it I'm gonna show
the answer in three two one right there
let's pretend that T should not be there
so what happens is there's an enzyme
that will come along and correct this
the good news is mutations can be
corrected errors can be corrected
because there are what we call
proofreading enzymes if you ever
proofread you know an essay you might
uncover grammar mistakes and spelling
mistakes and you can proofread and fix
well there's a proofreading enzyme and
because it's an enzyme I like to use
animated scissors to represent it and so
the proofreading enzyme has found the
misspelling has found the error and we
actually asked them estimate there's a
lot of errors in our DNA before the
proofreading happens we have about 6
billion a's t's c's and g's in every
cell of our body and before the repair
is made there's about we estimate about
10:1 error in every 10,000 of these a's
and T's and C's in G so we actually have
millions of these errors what happens is
the enzyme will splice out and remove
the mutation and that exposes an opening
and so hopefully the proper nucleotide
will float on in and now the enzyme or
now the mutation scuse me now the
mutation has been fixed and so post
repair it's estimated that there's maybe
only one error in every billion agent
ease and season G's so everyone has
mutations everyone has misspellings in
our DNA code and it's just we hope that
these mutations are not in areas of our
DNA code that could actually cause harm
to us and we'll talk more about that
later on in the school year how DNA
mutations can cause harm let's take a
quick moment and mention the other kind
of nucleic acid RNA ribonucleic
acid notice from the picture probably
the most obvious difference RNA is a
single chain of nucleotides whereas DNA
is a double chain of double helix notice
how there's some miss there's some
different spellings here when we examine
the nitrogen bases of RNA we still see a
four Adnan's and see four cytosines and
G for guanine
but notice how there's no t4 thymines we
have the letter U instead the letter U
is a nitrogen base called uracil and the
reason is thiamine cannot bond to the
sugar of RNA so that's why there's no
T's in RNA uracil can bind to the
different kind of sugar of RNA so that's
why you have used instead well let's
look at what RNA does well here's a
simple diagram of a cell and here's the
nucleus of the cell and inside the
nucleus is the DNA of the cell now as
we've said a few times
DNA is kind of like a set of
instructions of a blueprint and in DNA
are to be specific are the instructions
to build a protein but elsewhere in the
cell you have lots of parts of a cell
called a ribosome now ribosomes are
interesting because they're in the
cytoplasm but then you look at what they
do the ribosome is the actual builder of
the protein so you see we have a problem
we have the instructions to make the
protein in the nucleus but we have the
ribosome elsewhere in the cytoplasm so
something's missing
something must go in between the two and
that's the job of RNA RNA one of the
jobs of RNA is to make a temporary copy
of the DNA and carry it over to a
ribosome so there RNA is kind of like
the go between the intermediate molecule
it takes a copy of the DNA from the
nucleus over to the ribosome and now
that the ribosome has the instructions
to build a protein the ribosome will
begin to gather amino acids you might
know that amino acids are the monomers
or the building blocks of a protein and
so the ribosome gathers the amino acids
and they get linked
together to eventually make a protein
well let's do a little bit of review
before we're done so go ahead and pause
the video and try to fill in what goes
into box ABCDE NF pause the video some
of these were discussed other days of
course we only learned about nucleic
acids today but go ahead and try to fill
in as many of these as you can I'm gonna
go over the answer in three two one so a
monomer of a carbohydrate well that's a
monosaccharide a polymer of a
carbohydrate that's a polysaccharide
monomer of a protein that's an amino
acid a polymer of a protein that's a
polypeptide the monomer of a lipid
there's actually two of them a molecule
called fatty acid and a molecule called
glycerol and we talked about letter F
today the monomer of a nucleic acid
that's a nucleotide so how'd you do okay
so there you have it if you're in my
biology class you know pause the video
try to answer these questions on a
separate sheet of paper I'm happy to
check your answers before school or
after school one day so thanks for
watching hope you found this helpful